we're still looking at arithmetic
progressions arithmetic syriza's but
we're gonna apply them to some more
concrete problems okay so I'm waiting
for all eyes up I can see my spins are
down which is great all right so we
would have been having a look at these
problems right we just started kind of
with like two five eight random numbers
they could mean anything
but we want to do is say what do they
look like in a particular context and
then can we interpret the question
appropriately and then use the formulas
and things we've developed to solve the
problem okay so have a look at eleven
stay with me let's read it together but
slowly there's a lot to unpack a truck
spends the day depositing truckloads of
gravel from a quarry at equally spaced
intervals along a straight road pause
think about what that means okay let's
put the quarry somewhere on our page
let's call that Q for coy
okay and then what happens is this truck
it drives along this straight deposits
tombstone or gravel or whatever was a
gravel it's gravel right Scrabble thank
you deposit the gravel and then comes
back to the question more then it
returns to the next spot along the road
deposits gravel and then comes back and
it does this over and over again and
that's what we're trying to understand
here okay this is the same one we've
been in this exercise right so it's just
freshman 11 say okay all right so just
really quickly right this is the picture
in my head and maybe this is actually
worth picking your pet up now for to
just get a sense for the visual right it
goes somewhere and then he drops the
gravel in comes back right then he goes
again drops the gravel and then he comes
back and he repeats this process over
and over okay you you got the picture in
your head okay good now Shh it says the
first loads deposited 20 kilometers from
the quarry so we have a distance the
first noise deposited 20 corners from
the quarry the last load is 10
kilometers further along first one's 20
kilometers away last one's 10 further
along than that
all right so if the truck travels and
then they give you a total so after it's
gone up down up down up down up down
down at the Tetra right
it travels 550 kilometres in total and
then asks these two questions and
they're closely related how many trips
does it make how far apart are the
deposits okay first question how is it
that this produces an arithmetic
progression why is there an arithmetic
progression that flows out of this
situation
[Music]
yep yep okay so motor scene is a
constant difference and I think what we
tend to use is common right so it's like
this distance here is in common with
this distance here and it just keeps
going along so that the gravel piles end
up equally spaced that's what it says
right it's not a question okay now
what's tricky about this is we don't
know how many different like spots it
stops at right and we don't know how far
apart those are so it seems like do we
know enough information to make this out
I want you to look back at the second
sentence in the question read it again
with me it says the first load is
deposited 20 kilometers from the quarry
the last is 10 kilometers further along
the road so being that we've got these
two different forms for describing the
sum of an arithmetic sequence let me
just whoops that's it - okay let's have
a look right which of these read the
second sentence again which of these do
you think would be more helpful first or
the second now what we're trying to do
is work out what's going on in this
situation how many track travels how
many number trips do we know how many
trips
that's the question how many trips I
have no clue right ham times a stop so I
want you to look and tell me what a and
L stand for the first and the last have
a look at the question
even says the first load is and then it
says the last is so that's kind of what
clues you win that this is the form
that's gonna be more useful to me okay
right okay so I also have a total
distance so let's go ahead let's use
this guy right I've got a total distance
it's 550 that's a messy five kilometers
what's that equal to now I don't know
what n is that's kind of the problem
right okay I don't know what n is ends
what I'm trying to solve so I'm not
gonna substitute anything for that but
then what I have to do is work out what
a and L are now look carefully they give
us some distances but they're not quite
the distances we need look carefully the
first layer is deposited twenty
kilometers from the quarry so here it is
20 kilometers away so what does one
journey actually look like you've got to
get to the twenty but but then you've
got to go back right do you see that's
why I drew it out every journey so
that's why as surely I said it's gonna
be 40 because you got to go there and
then come back to the quarry is that all
right so there's my first term then I
need a last term now the last one my
scale is terrible here but the last
journey is 10 kilometers further over
right so how far is it from the quarry
it's 20 I know you're going one step
ahead it's ten corners further so it's
30 kilometers away which means I've got
to go thirty there thirty back that
gives me my total which is sixty does
that make sense
you with me so far now this is really
good because now I can actually sort out
what n is right what shall I do
yeah very good n over two times a
hundred what's the on two gonna give me
okay hold on a second so you're dividing
across but I'd like to do this first I
think it'll be easier for me 100 why why
- that's 50
okay so now and is just going to be
divide both sides by 500 50/50 okay so
look quickly the question have we
answered it yet how many trips is a make
that's the answer okay but then the next
question is how far apart are the
deposits I'm gonna hit pause and let you
have a think about that while you try
and work it out